he's winning every map every tournament
almost every MVP has insane stats and is
quite literally pioneering Counter
Strike into a new age and no I'm not
talking about
simple okay so before we get into the
video quick friendly reminder that we
have new merch guess what folks our
touch grass hoodies did so well that the
suit are actually letting us make even
more dumb gamer inspired like our
new Bader zipup hoodies made for all the
real blue collar workers out there
perfect for any environment whether it's
catching fish hanging your teammates out
to dry or just tugging on your or how
about our inspiring you onward and
forward te the ideal shirt for the
sweatiest of Gamers so that you can slam
the W key with zero resistance and
little to no chafing teammates don't
like it them ruin everyone's night oh
and yeah we got these blue Esports te's
I forgot we made these uh yeah they're
definitely blue and they say Esports
game in style and comfort with the score
Esports drop two available now if any of
that looks sick to you head over to
shop. thescore.com so yeah Robs a couple
days ago rs' teammate twists put out
this seemingly spicy but honestly
completely sensible tweet saying that
cs2s native son was in fact the best in
the world and let's be honest he he kind
of just is now to be clear I'm not
suggesting that just because homie's on
a hot streak that he's all of a sudden
indefinitely better than zyu or simple
what I am saying is that right now if
you look at the numbers he is
unquestionably the best competitor in
the game 15 straight Maps three straight
tournaments two of the three MVPs that
have been handed out so far and a slew
of absurdly consistent stats the guy is
is an animal and that's
cool see what I did there but that's not
really why we're here robs has always
been a generational talent and I said
for years in csgo that he was still
being underrated even when he was a top
10 player in the world the reason we're
really here is because of the stuff he's
doing outside of the server or you know
outside of competitive servers you see
pretty much the second that CS2 launched
robs was living and breathing this game
from tick rate experiments to labbing
sick utility lineups lil bro has been on
that grind while the rest of us have
been complaining endlessly about how
awful CS2 is and trust me I too am
guilty of that homie has been working
every day to improve it and that's
amazing honestly it's great for CS2 it's
great for the community and it's great
for Rob's trophy case unfortunately it
has caused people to draw sort of
disparaging comparisons between the 169
goat and the actual goat also can we
just take a second to point out the
Strays that my boy Z is catching from
this scrawny tweet you know the the 50
Cent meme I'm like what do you say me
for that's literally Z waking up and
seeing this tweet you see since the
launch of CS2 simple has been pretty
vocal about his dislike for it so much
so that he encouraged aspiring
competitors to basically just not play
it until it felt better this inspired
valve to reach out to him privately and
ask what he thought the issues were and
well he left them on red you know what I
did I never answered them back how can
you ask me what's the issue if the whole
internet whole Twitter writing about
issues I know simple has been catching a
ton of heat for this and I said it
at the time and I'll say it again now I
actually think this was a pretty based
move and I respect him for it I'll tell
you why all of us you me me casters
competitors creators we've all been very
vocal about what the issues with CS2
actually are it's plastered all over
social media for better and for worse so
for valve to just reach out to simple
and say wait so well what are the issues
it's like borderline offensive now I'm
not saying that that's necessarily the
tone in which they meant to convey it
but I seem to think that that's how
simple interpreted it it seems like what
he felt was sort of ins sensed that the
developer would only care to hear
grievances from the goat as if they were
turning a blind eye to everyone else's
opinions except for his so what he did
was Ghost them and basically just convey
this idea of look the issues are well
documented all over the Internet you
don't need me to spell them out for you
now I understand this is a bit of a hot
take and I'm not saying that simple
couldn't have responded and actually
just explicitly said this stuff to Val
but I do think that what he did was
actually respectful of the
Counter-Strike Community not a slight
his intentions were Noble I think and
for people to just on him for not
saving Counterstrike is just insane and
unfair the other issue is that a lot of
this sympathy towards valve or
understanding of their predicament is
sort of retroactive we only know that
valve are genuinely trying their best
and adopting an actual sense of humility
through all of this because robs told
hltv that valve said this to him
privately and now
I feel for them I do but I didn't when
they were radio silent as I was getting
railed through Walls by Ferrari
peaking P90s we all know that
communication is not vals suit never has
been in any of their games in fact
there's a long history of it being
maddening just how deafening their
silence actually is so for them to
finally offer one morsel of transparency
to one person and then have the entire
Community rise up and be like oh yeah
guys no come on like you know they're
they're really trying their best it's
just insane like there's no way our
Stockholm syndrome is that bad now some
of you might interpret this as me
ragging on RS or the approach that he
opted to take and I assure you that I am
not categorically one I worship RS I
always have you can check the tapes he
is my 169 goat two the good that he is
doing for CS2 cannot be overstated was
simple's approach understandable yes I
really think it was was it callous Petty
even sure but that doesn't mean that it
wasn't on some level warranted was
simple approach understandable yes I
really think it was was it callous Petty
even yes but that doesn't mean that it
wasn't in some sense Justified the fact
that robs Rose above it shows that he
really is the best of us like scrawny
said a consummate professional who cares
deeply about Counterstrike could simple
have gotten a humble reply from valve
had he not left them on
red maybe probably but I still
understand why he reacted the way he did
the way he described it valve's initial
message to simple did come off as sort
of toned deaf and I think that that's
how he interpreted it it isn't healthy
or sustainable for valve to only offer
transparency to like a handful of people
in the community like you have to be
robs or simple for your opinion
to count for anything and I could be
wrong but I think that that's what
simple was trying to rebel against now
should the opinion of a simple or a robs
carry more weight than the average mg2
redditor yes obviously but it can't be
the only thing that valve gives the time
a day to anyway rant over the takeaway
from all of this is that robs is a God
and I respect and appreciate him
immensely but I also respect and
appreciate the goat and the way that he
stood up for the Counter-Strike
Community which Again by my Reckoning is
what he did I don't care how much simple
dislikes CS2 I dislike CS2 we all on
some level dislike CS2 don't get me
wrong the game's getting a lot better
but there's still a lot of things about
it that are eminently dislikable so why
is it that simple's the only one who's
not allowed to air his frustrations
about the game and valve's handling of
it does he have some ethical obligation
to make the game better I mean you could
actually argue that he does what you
can't argue is that he has to do it on
anyone's terms that are not his own let
simple cook the way simple Cooks just
like we let robs cook the way robs Cooks
who's to say one didn't affect the other
that valve didn't look at the simple
debacle and use it to re-evaluate their
interactions going forward all any of us
want is for CS2 to get better so let's
stop ragging on each other and just
focus on
that oh this was we shot this in person
at an undisclosed location and then the
video file was corrupt so we had to
re-shoot it at home but it's sad we we
were very excited to tease tease the new
location soon TM not valve time not
valve time actual actual soon yeah yeah
actual soon TM